hi everyone what's up I'm Alana which
are lanza and welcome to my channel
today I'm going to be answering question
that people have asked me a couple of
times across the years but I haven't
actually addressed because reasons so
that's what camera I use for YouTube and
right now you're watching me on a Canon
550d which as some of you have noticed
recently has a few dead pixels now I
bought a new camera maybe two months ago
and the reason that I've held off on
making a what camera do you use video is
because I don't really feel like the
550d is ideal for YouTube the new camera
that I bought is great for it I should
preface this by saying that I know very
very little about cameras I have done
quite a bit of research into what I
think that I need but some of my
terminology may be incorrect here so
sorry about that I'm not a camera
reviewer so I bought a Panasonic Lumix
DMC gh3 and it's beautiful has one of
those which I'm really happy about so
one of the things that I don't like
about the 550d is that I can't actually
see what you guys are looking at so
sometimes I'm like oh is this fitted in
frame and I actually have no idea and
that's extremely frustrating so with
this you can flip it around so you can
see what you're looking at at all times
at the same time another thing that I
think is really important for YouTube
they've learned over the years of having
videos not in focus is that this will
autofocus so for those who aren't
familiar with the time it basically
means that wherever I'm sitting it will
know and focus on me so that I'm not
blurry or whatever which sometimes I am
in the 550d so the lens that I have is
honestly not ideal for YouTube this is
what my work asks me to get for work
related stuff and this is 150 millimeter
which I would suggest for YouTube
probably about 35 millimeter it's gonna
be better if I want this to look at my
face it's can you see you can see my
face here this is how zoom businesses
right so when I'm here it's like that
but if I were filming with this in the
same distance you would just be able to
see my mouth that is not a product of
the camera that is a product of the lens
which is really not ideal for YouTube so
after briefly using it things that I
particularly like about the gh3 is the
light it seems to pick up light it's so
well without getting grainy the
autofocus is
virtually silent so even though your
lens is adjusting you can't really hear
it at all now this thing is also a
touchscreen so if you want to adjust
what you're focusing on on the go you
just press it and it will change focus
which i think is fantastic it's sixteen
point zero five megapixels with a lot of
MOS sensor as well got six frames per
second continuous shooting and in full
HD 60 frames a second or fifty frames a
second video in 1080p all year there's
also a headphone jack built-in which is
awesome and a microphone jack built in
there as well so effectively it seemed
to be one of the few cameras it has all
of the things that I want and others gh2
that works pretty similarly this does
have some upgrades and there's also a
gh4 if you want that but I'm very happy
with the gh3 and I'm gonna show you guys
what it looks like now just I'm just
gonna have to stand really far back and
they look about to hear me because the
lens is terrible so I'm just gonna show
you guys the autofocus and the light now
this is a very darkly lit room this is
my Hylian Shield Hylian Shield again
watch dhaka this is where it gets really
dark but you can still see things
extremely well here
and everything appears to be in focus no
matter how far away it is which is
pretty great
those aren't so you just sorta just a
bit there so that was probably slower
than it normally would be because this
lens isn't very good but it's nice that
you just want do it and then we have
some more stuff down the bottom so this
is like the depths of my bedroom where
it's extremely dark and everything still
looks fantastically light and another
adjustment there and in focus yeh
so I know of course I'm not a camera
review I'm not that snazzy with cameras
but these are just the reasons why I
chose it and why I think it's perfect
for what I've done compared to a lot of
other cameras out there so if you know
more about cameras feel free to let
people know some some stuff that I want
to mist out or more specific details in
the comments below because I really
mostly just know stuff about video games
so yeah I'm Alana I thank you guys for
watching I'll see you next time